vladimir putin ha sido ubicar muy claro
ha dicho que rusia no está ahora mismo
en disposiciones de hacer obra obras de
caridad esto significa según ha
explicado él con sus propias palabras
que los contratos que no se paguen serán
suspendidos y esos países dejarán de
recibir el suministro ruso durante los
últimos días
putin ha hablado con diversos jefes de
estado y de gobiernos
el caso de graciosos de alemania también
el primer ministro italiano dalí y al
menos por lo que estos ejes de gobierno
extranjeros europeos han dicho habían
conseguido acordar con rusia que al
menos de momento al menos mientras se
adaptan a la nueva situación pudiesen
pagar en euros pero el anuncio de hoy de
la de mi punto es muy claro muy duro y
de la sensación de que no sabemos si a
corto plazo pero desde luego a medio
plazo europa saber en la disyuntiva de
pagar en rublos o en que renunciar al
gas ruso y ahora mismo en muchos países
europeos que no están preparados para
ello